foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday March 9th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Google has spent billions developing
artificial intelligence technology it's
been a leader in the field so it was
surprising to some when its rival
Microsoft seemed to gain an edge in the
AI space through its deal with open AI
the maker of chat GPT
so how did Google seemingly give up its
lead
with me to discuss that is wsj Google
reporter miles Krupa hey miles thanks
for joining us thanks Zoe So before we
get into the position Google is in now
can you tell us a bit about what Google
has been working on what kind of
Investments it's made in AI over the
years Google was really a leader in AI
among the big tech companies as far back
as 2011 they set up this Research Unit
called Google brain led by this
researcher Jeff Dean he was very well
respected they've pumped out a lot of
research they're one of the biggest
producers of AI research anywhere from
Academia to Corporate America so they've
sort of been working behind the scenes
to infuse that into things like search
YouTube even things like Google
Translate is really heavily powered by
artificial intelligence so it's been
kind of simmering in the background for
a while what about big developments like
chat Bots people may now be familiar
with chat GPT has Google spent time
developing something like that it turns
out they have they've been developing or
looking at developing these things for
years many years so back when Google was
run by Larry Page one of the co-founders
he was really interested in this thing
called the technological singularity the
idea that machines would one day be as
intelligent as humans and so he brought
in this guy Ray Kurzweil who was a big
popularizer of this idea and Rey started
working on chat Bots himself then later
this researcher who was actually at
YouTube at the time working as a
software engineer Daniel de Freitas he
started spending some of his extra time
to work on a chat bot originally called
Mina okay so they have this chat bot why
hasn't it been released to the world for
many reasons that Google would say are
very good reasons and many outside of
Google would say are overly cautious
reasons
um you know this thing went through
multiple iterations uh they started
working on it in 2018
released the first paper about it in
2020 and even as far back as 2020 they
wanted to open it up to researchers hand
selected researchers who could come in
and play with it right there was a
company called open AI that had done
some things very similar with something
called gpt2 openai who
I who familiar with that open AI that
open AI yes the one that is now backed
by Microsoft okay so Google wanted to
open their chat bot to researchers did
it what happened with that yeah so
Daniel and people working on his team
really wanted researchers to have access
to this and they applied for permission
to do that what they heard in response
was that it didn't quite meet these
seven AI principles that Google had
developed a few years earlier trying to
guard against AI producing unfair biased
inaccurate harmful content and other you
know repercussions for broader Society
right so they were basically told no
this will remain internal
what happened when they were told no
what sort of happened with those
researchers and with Google's research
since then they kept pushing on this
other researcher at Google brain gnome
Shazier
joined and he really worked with Daniel
on making this chat bot even larger
built on even more data and even more
computing power this was a time when
openai and other companies were sort of
realizing scale is King you know let's
make this as big as possible so they
kept working on that it was eventually
renamed to Lambda which is its name now
and they were trying to get this out to
the world in different ways in one
scenario they wanted this to be part of
Google Assistant The Voice powered thing
that's on your home devices or phones
you ask hey Google maybe Lambda in the
background would be responding so that
was one idea what they really wanted was
a public demo and for many reasons they
would not get that public demo so what
happened with the Lambda developers are
they still at Google still working on
the next iteration of this they are not
they eventually got so frustrated by
their attempts to release this thing and
being told no they decided to quit in
late 2021 and when they decided to quit
my understanding is that Sundar pichai
the CEO of Google ended up sort of
personally trying to make an appeal to
them you know stay continue to work on
Lambda were dedicated to this project
we'll give you more resources but he
stopped short of telling them that he
would release it to the public and so
that wasn't good enough for them they
wanted to go and start their own company
which they have it's called character
have we heard from them have they
commented on this story they would not
talk to me for this story but they have
spoken generally in the past about how
it was difficult to do something like
this at Google and easier to do at a
startup has Google commented at all
about these researchers leaving or about
not releasing Lambda to the public
Google's stance is basically it was a
cool prototype but there's a big Gulf
between a prototype and a product that's
ready for millions or potentially
billions of people to use and it didn't
quite bridge that Gulf at the time you
know they stand by their AI principles
which are still guiding their
development today of AIA technology
and they said Lambda went through
multiple reviews and yes we did shut it
down now it's finally actually getting
to the point of releasing this to the
public right now things are different
we've got chat GPT going viral you've
got Microsoft working with open Ai and
so where does Google go from here at the
atheist still has popular browser the
most popular search engine the most
popular mobile operating system it just
has so many surface areas in which it
can introduce this technology and Google
has a history of being second and
winning it was second in search second
in mobile operating systems and Sundar
is actually pointed to this internally
told employees
we are not always first but we often
become the largest because we build user
trust over time that's our Google
reporter miles Krupa thanks for joining
us miles thanks Zoe all right that's it
for today's Tech news briefing but a
quick note on AI before we close the
show we want to hear your questions
about generative artificial intelligence
AI programs like chat GPT Microsoft's
new Bing search or mid-journey and we're
going to answer them on an upcoming
episode do you want to know more about
how these AI programs work what they're
capable of or maybe what this latest
wave of AI development could mean for
how we live our lives
email us a voice recording with your AI
question to tnb at wsj.com or leave us a
voicemail on
415-439-6482 we look forward to hearing
from you
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]